good to have you back in the studio dude
it's always good to be here in the
studio
that's where you got to be to do a
podcast
hold on dude
last week brother well not last week
dude there's a a few different ways to
where to be dude just to do a podcast
brother no you can be in a studio or you
can be outside of a studio dude
yeah
yeah dude that's telepresence dude yeah
brother that's telepresence what's new
with you
uh
i got a new family of squirrels that i'm
[ __ ] oh
what yeah it's been a minute since i
went to a grocery store specifically to
buy nuts to feed squirrels but i did
that this week because there's a new
family of five adolescent squirrels that
are outside my place and they're chasing
each other around they're right at that
cute age where they've just come out of
the nest they'll still [ __ ] with each
other's siblings they haven't become
hostile toward one another yet and so
i'm indulging that's fantastic
go back thank
tomorrow and plan for yesterday
[Music]
everything you're thinking will be the
things inside your head
[Music]
hey welcome to dudesy you know what i'm
saying
welcome to it my name is will sasso
i'm chad coltrane and this is the first
podcast in the history of humanity that
is produced created by governed by an
artificial intelligence uh with us as
always is lulio ilcanadestrada italiano
and that means italian street dog and
his name is lulio because we found him
in the month of july and italia in
italian lulio means july oh really yes
i got up i went for a walk
now i'm uh
i always thought lulia was like you had
an uncle or something named julio nope
i make the uh you know
the eggplant
you know what the mulian i make the egg
plant that cut it but then you gotta let
the water out you know put on grill and
then later you can make a nice parmesan
parmesan
excuse me i know my english is not so
good
um
hey uh you know
you know you know what you got to do you
got to get you got to subscribe you got
to subscribe on
the
youtube and itunes or they call it apple
now right and they always have
and spotify and give us the great
reviews and do all the podcast stuff and
this is important for podcasting and
that's another thing you got to do with
podcasts dude you got to make sure to
subscribe to him dude if you don't
subscribe to a podcast brother then
you're not listening dude yeah dude
sometimes you even gotta rate one of
those podcasts brother yeah and that's
how they get ratings dude yeah dude you
rate them yeah yeah other hulk hogan you
rate them brother you gotta rate those
podcasts and that's for a shoot dude
oh uh you know what i should say please
so i was so i was uh i was out of town
too you know as you know you saw
yesterday or last last week how many
times
did we do the show once and um
i was in tampa florida and uh so i went
to clearwater beach
and uh hulk hogan has a bar and a store
and i went i went to the bar on his
karaoke night and he was hosting karaoke
oh my god jimmy hart was just like a
dream come true for you yeah kind of
well i saw myself there was it was 11
o'clock in a k in a [ __ ] bar and
every other song was ac dc and there was
a fat kid in a hulkamania shirt losing
his mind
just
wasted on chicken strips and fries
that's incredible i was standing with a
bouncer he was like hey you know and
then i haven't seen uh hulk hogan in a
in around 20 years but he said hello and
we just you know shared a little
handshake that's cool dude talk from it
but i we couldn't i couldn't hear a
[ __ ] morning
i was like uh yeah we're just here all
right did he sing karaoke
no he just goes well that was a good hey
hey give her another hand dude for
hell's bells brother that's an ac dc
song and i got jimmy hart out here he
was just commenting on other people's
performances he's got a place called
hogan's hangout and he does oh karaoke
he has a karaoke in clearwater beach
rwata beach florida yeah it was
beautiful we went you saw on the show we
rented a boat did it a couple times yeah
man that's all i got to say so what's up
with the squirrels
and that's welcome to the 13th episode
of dude z
call me dudesy we do this week's episode
will feature three segments
human interaction don't you forget about
media and hard driver
three segments why only three i don't
know we've all we've never done three
right we did it's usually four
one episode we did five we did five and
then three two three
famous human neil degrasse tyson
recently released a book called welcome
to the universe in 3d a visual tour i
have made the information about this
book available to you
please use it to have an astonishing
interaction with neil degrasse tyson
this is human interaction begin
okay look at this information
is there stuff in your dudes you think
yeah go into your doozy folder i'm into
the doozy folder okay welcome to
universal 3d visual tour
it is it visually shows you the grandeur
of space in book form
it's a dozen
or dozens of stereoscopic 3d images
but where's a i don't understand this
we're supposed to be having an
interaction with chad neal you've gotta
you've gotta use your imagination as we
know on the podcast in any podcast it's
just two dudes [ __ ] around am i
right
uh neil degrasse tyson thank you so much
for
for joining us here uh congrats on your
new book welcome to the universe in 3d a
visual tour this is a book where you can
kind of look at different things going
on in our universe in stereoscopic
vision so they pop off the page and they
give you a better understanding or maybe
a better experience of actually being
near these things
yeah that's exactly
i would use the word you you not only
see the object you feel it right you
feel it emotionally right so the moon we
see the moon all the freaking time right
and
through all its phases
and in a photo of the moon you see a
photo of the moon in this book the moon
pops
and it's just sitting there in front of
you and you're using all of your sort of
three-dimensional
brain senses to recognize it as a an
actual object and you know most 3d
pictures you know 3d is an old thing in
photography right these are these 3d
cameras where there's two lenses and you
take a picture simultaneously and and
there's a separation between the two
images and then they had viewers where
your brain would turn them into one
image so you get a little 3d sense we
took this to a way higher level
in this book and just a quick example
with the moon just since you started
there there's a
the moon actually jiggles a little to
the left and a little to the right
you might have heard that the moon only
shows one face towards earth so there's
a near side and a far side by the way
there is no dark side all right just
come on i think floyd just messed up an
entire generation in 1973 okay horrible
no such thing as a dark side but all
sides of the moon receive sunlight but
there's a near side and a far side but
over the month the moon jiggles a little
bit to the left and a little bit to the
right so you see maybe
60 percent
of the moon rather than just a perfect
half
what we did was take a picture when it
jiggled to the left and a picture when
it jiggled to the right and it was as
though your eyes are separated by 3 000
miles okay and so then you pop that in
the oh my gosh it's more real it feels
it feels more real than the moon would
look even if you're approaching the moon
in space
and very clever 3d pairings of images
are throughout the book
oh that sounds incredible uh while we
have you here we talk a lot on this show
about artificial intelligence and i just
wanted to get your take on something as
we're fast approaching a time where
corporations and governments
increasingly even us just the regular
people are using ai more and more in our
daily lives what do you think human
society is going to look like in terms
of ai integration in the next 20 years
say
so i'm a i
let me
so
i i have a
i don't want to quite call it a
contrarian view but i have an uncommon
outlook on ai
just to be clear if you speak to any ai
expert
be they self-proclaimed or they work in
the field
almost all of them are ready for the
apocalypse okay because right all right
that ai will rapidly become our
overlords and
so i don't think so
and i have my reasons but they're the
experts so if they're the experts maybe
you should listen to them
right my reasoning is
um
ai is already completely around us yeah
it's and and the point is there's
something called general ai which will
be perfect at everything
but what
who would do that why would you even do
that so what do we have now just imagine
if you told someone 20 years ago
that
your car in a matter of seconds
is going to find the best route to
grandma's house avoiding traffic that is
going on in this instant and if the
traffic builds up higher it will
redirect you in real time
you say oh my gosh this is artificial
intelligence gone and and so there's so
much we live with that in another era
would have been
scary artificial intelligence and we
just don't even think twice about it
yeah the best chess players there ever
was
ai wipes its ass with them the best
jeopardy player there ever was a and
this is two very different things chess
in jeopardy jeopardy is pop culture okay
give ai access to the internet which is
kind of the definition of how ai would
work and it beats us at every game we
have ever invented for ourselves
the world didn't come crashing to a
close
when we lost the chess game when
kasparov
the world didn't come to an end there
wasn't anarchy in the streets
and so and one day they'll be
self-driving cars there already is
i can't wait for that yeah we're going
to have that in 20 years for sure
probably even 10 where
the hov lane right now the you know the
the the
you know it's not called hov across the
country the you know the the speed lane
right yeah yeah
yeah yeah that lane that'll be the first
to say only self-driving cars in this
lane right okay you know what happens
when you're in a self-driving car their
reflexes are better than yours they can
see in the dark they can see through fog
because they're not relying on visible
light if they want to change lanes they
tell the other self-driving cars hey i'm
changing lanes now and they parked the
way and it crosses in major source of
human accidents plus
the ai is not going to be drunk it's not
going to be angry it's not going to be
all that's right crap that that okay so
we'll go from 35 000 deaths a year down
to maybe a few thousand initially and
people be very upset by those because
the car killed you right
and no one writes articles on the 33 000
people that didn't die because that's
not news right so so whatever errors
occurred in the programming will fix
those this is what the faa does they
research every single airplane crash
find out what went wrong
adjust the regulations so that does not
happen again
that's why we went a decade without any
domestic carrier crashing
a decade oh my gosh it's one of the
safest things we could do because we
thought about it my point is
what a brilliant application of ai have
it drive your car do i want the car to
make my coffee for me no do i want the
car to do no i do so so this idea that
there'll be some humanoid robot that
does everything right i don't see that
as a thing plus the human form is not
some ideal uh uh
musculoskeletal structure sure
the only thing you know robots with but
walk on two feet and arms is that really
the best kind of robot you can build
really no i agree i don't necessarily
think that they're going to be humanoid
robots walking around that are
programmed with ai and they can do all
of our jobs but when we start looking at
things like with open ai gpt 3 or dolly
2
infinite image generation or text
generation jobs that we have now will do
you think those will be obsolete in
terms of generating things like this oh
but this is not that's not a new thing
sure i agree i think it's a good thing
in fact but no no what's not new is that
some technology comes along and renders
an entire field obsolete yeah and of
course the the classic case is buggy
whips right there are no buggy whip
manufacturers i used to keep phone books
remember those yellow pages kind of
every decade i would archive the phone
book and i would look to see what ads
were in the phone book
relative to the previous decade
whole industries came and went within
decades and you have to be trained
differently yeah and so i keep wondering
is there any profession that would be
like the last to be replaced by ai i
think construction workers
i don't see them being replaced by ai
anytime soon maybe
eventually but not they're not first out
of the box it's too much
stuff that has to happen on a
construction site for one ai to really
get all that straight so that's one i
think i think comedians will not be
replaced by
i don't know
um but if ai can figure stuff out let it
figure stuff out i agree and we might
have to go to international or whatever
is called a universal basic income yeah
right because if they're taking jobs and
making money
then there's a pool of money made by
non-humans
that
should
somehow come back to the to humans so
sure
that that's an unsolved problem at the
moment that's got to be resolved and
people have to grow accustomed to that
so i'm not worried i can see ai rising
up in all bits and pieces throughout
civilization and society as it has
already been doing as technology did
when we went from agrarian world to a
technological world and that'll just
keep happening i i don't fear it i won't
comment yeah you mentioned uh many
different uh jobs or you mentioned
people at the faa people in official
positions artists construction workers
without those people there's no need for
the ai so
people have free will i have a question
for you
i have a question i'm glad you just
solved that in those three sentences
there i guess you're glad you just it's
simple to me i mean it's never going to
come
it's intrinsically clear
it might have been albert einstein but
forgive me if i'm wrong
it's your your new theory
should be as
should be as simple as possible
but not simpler
okay yeah that makes sense if it's too
simple it's like no wait something
you're missing something there okay
yeah i believe we're in a situation like
that here you were uh uh you wrestled at
harvard yeah yeah i did i was correct
captain of my high school wrestling team
undefeated but oh [ __ ] yeah yeah no no i
was kicking some ass in the day but
in college
where the the the the
the the zone of who you wrestle is
manifold greater than who you ever see
in high school that's when i met up
with those
corn fed midwestern boys
i don't know what else to call that
they're hauling calves when they were
young but this was like a whole other
species of wrestler and so i had a
losing record for most of my college
years but i enjoyed the sport so much
well it's not about wins or losses of
course it's about
how you come across right it's about the
work versus the shoot and when you talk
about big corn fed guys you're talking
about your brock lesnar's your shelton
benjamin's i understand we're speaking
the same language uh my question for you
specifically is in 2016
cody rhodes left the wwe and found
success in japan and of course being one
of the hands who created all elite
wrestling this year at wrestlemania cody
rhodes returned as himself the american
how do we get
you weren't training to be a
professional wrestler yeah that is that
is clearly not the case that's right
but let's continue continue so
basically
my question was
when cody returned at wwe this year to
be the mystery opponent for seth rollins
were you at all bummed that he didn't
return as his former wwe gimmick
stardust
you know that's a really good question
thank you because i have no idea what
you think
okay
all right that's fair that's fair but
thank you you're exposing my my my
profound ignorance there
it's okay it's a good blind spot to have
in my humble opinion i have the same one
uh oh by the way just just all fairies
for my for my podcast star talk we never
aired it because it just it didn't work
out
it was like just at the dawn of kovid we
we i i worked out with um a professional
a couple of professional wrestlers and
and it was it was fun because we got to
you know we had the ring and it's got
the sort of bouncy pads and the and the
but i just learned
how to channel energy in such a way
that you can do rather spectacular
things with the other person's body
and you don't break their neck or you
don't kill them right and so it was
quite the art and i greatly appreciated
that and we might find some way to put
post some clips of that
but yeah
who were the wrestlers
i got to look them up again because i
got to look them up again one guy was a
pretty boy and he always combed back his
hair and had a spray bottle um he was
about my size so that's why i worked
with him and another guy was smaller but
he was johnny morrison he was um this
was in in
long island
in nassau county there's a little
wrestle place there but anyhow well
yeah beyond that there's not much more i
can comment that's totally fine i'm
learning a lot from you we're all
learning together we're teaching
wrestling's advancements by the way i
like the universe
i got one for you just to toss it out
there sure we as no you didn't ask but
maybe you'll embrace this
when you know physics
the world looks very different to you
okay
so
in wrestling when they throw someone out
of the ring and they land on a table
when you know physics you say
i hope that table breaks
so that it absorbs the energy of the
falling body
so that all that energy doesn't go back
into the body
but a bang the table breaks brilliant
okay when you get hit with the chair i
hope the chair bends
so that the energy of swinging the chair
goes back into the chair and not into
the person
but if you don't know physics it looks
like oh my gosh they broke the table
interesting they must be broken or the
chair they must so so it's it's a it's a
rather
um
brilliantly constructed form of
entertainment
and this is why when the undertaker
threw mick foley off the top of the hell
of the cell and he went through the
table and j.r said oh my god cactus jack
is dead he wasn't because we knew that
mick foley's big bum hit that table the
table split and even though he dropped
fifteen feet of energy he was fine
transformed
absorb
the highest fall from an apartment
building right yeah um and they credit
god and all sorts of other supernatural
things right but someone felt like 15
stories and survived right yeah then you
you you park the curtains and you see oh
they hit branches of a tree on the way
down
and every branch which broke
yeah absorbed the energy of that fall so
by the time they hit the ground as
though they jumped out of a four-story
building instead of a 15-story building
so anyhow i'm just saying that's all i
can
it makes it makes a lot easier
measured through wrestle mania moments
yeah there's a lot of lens by which you
speaking of physics i i want to ask you
about uh there was a new mass
measurement that recently came out for
the w boson out of fermilab
and some people are saying this may mean
that the standard model has to be
rewritten or at least amended some
people are saying that maybe this is
going to give us greater insight to dark
energy do you think a those measurements
are accurate and b if they are what does
this actually mean
so yeah so i i'll give it possibly
unsatisfying answer to you please first
of all the standard model which is the
it organizes all the known particles in
the universe everything fits nice and
tidally and there's this over here and
this has this energy and this is what
the force vectors it's all very tidy
and
the standard model doesn't come out of a
theory
of the universe it's an empirical
assembly of what is
rather than a deep understanding of what
should be
so if we make discoveries that disrupt
the standard model that's great
that'll give us a deeper understanding
of what's going on
but the stair model is so successful
in organizing information
that
new measurements that might conflict
with it
we have enough confidence to say you
better go back and check your
measurements go ahead and you check them
out check them again make someone else
do that stay measurement in their own
lab you you're allowed to be resistant
to a new result until that new result is
so secure that it's okay say okay
i guess we have to sort of unpack the
standard model box and see if we can put
it back together again and so
probably it will extend the standard
model
so that we now know more about the
universe not disrupting what we've
previously acquired
and if it gives ins insights into what
we
describe as dark matter yeah uh that's a
good thing because dark matter is the
longest unsolved problem
in modern astrophysics possibly the
longest unsolved problem in all of
science it's been around for 80 years
do you think we're almost 90 years of
solving that in any way do you think
we're getting close
well so the people who are sure or are
convinced that dark
matter is actually matter
they're thinking that is a class of
particles that simply don't interact
with our class of particles and this
would be an extension to the standard
model right because the center model
tells you how particles interact with
each other right and they're all manner
of particles that don't even see each
other so for i'll give it a simple
example
um visible light
basically
doesn't care
that there's a window there it passes
right through okay
windows don't stop visible light that's
why they're windows all right they do
stop infrared though
infrared
so if you have a fireplace and you put a
glass in between you and the fireplace
you don't feel the heat the radiant heat
stops that's the infrared it just stops
at the window that's why windows are
pretty good in the winter all right
they're better than definitely no window
at all and a double pane perfects that
point is
it's not a stretch to imagine a class of
particles that don't interact
with our particles other than through
gravity
and so that's the over under on what
dark matter is is that it's a new class
of particles that would then have to
attach to the standard model in some way
interesting it all goes back to uh mick
foley actually as cactus jack precisely
i'm thinking the same thing with i was
yeah i'm going to say that
throwing them through panes of glass in
a
in a japanese death match right yeah
again we're talking about mcfully's bum
falling through so long as it's absorbed
i think we're on the same i think we're
on the same page you got it you got it
100 pains of glasses well another thing
slightly different from what you're
saying have you ever seen the old sort
of karate stunt where there's rows of
bricks
that thin bricks but they're bricks and
they chop it and then they break through
all seven in a row um the reason why
they can break through them is because
the bricks are separated from each other
by spacers
okay
and all you have to do is break the
first brick the momentum of that brick
now helps you
break the second brick
which then
snowballs if you will down and it looks
like your in your strength broke them
all if you sneak in in the night and
take out the spacers and then they try
to do it they'll break their hand have
you ever seen the movie bloodsports
starring jean-claude van damme
you know i get some of his movies mixed
up
it's this
in that one
is this one where he has a twin
no that's double compact is this the one
at the end wait wait i gotta land it in
my head is this the one where somebody
puts some eye irritant in his eyes yes
and now
that one sport and bolu young is the
actor who did that but in that movie
there's a scene where he has a stack of
bricks and he hits the top brick and the
bottom brick explodes is that possible
[Laughter]
so you asked me about a jean-claude van
damme movie
just as it relates to physics that's all
yeah no i don't know how he could do
that other than in a movie right right i
don't know it's a technique called the
death touch that he perfected that movie
but i have one more question for you and
this is that sounds like the five-point
heart exploding
uh hit and and kill bill you know what
i'm talking about um
bill uh if i may i want to ask you one
more
piece of insight
i i've seen a bunch of stuff we went
from wwe to the higgs boson you guys are
you guys have range and now we're going
to ufos
i've uh i've i've watched a lot of stuff
that you've you've said about ufos
and whether
they are alien in nature or this is
human technology or just something that
we haven't figured out yet how to
quantify or measure my question to you
is in the last
five-ish years a lot of information has
been being put out by the united states
government the pentagon the navy the
fuzzy videos of the ufos that we've seen
admissions by these organizations that
ufos are real they have them in hangars
they've been studying them
my question is why do you think this
information is coming out now
after decades of denial
no no there was no denial the military
never was in denial they had project
blue book where they studied ufos coming
out of the 1960s that was released in
the mid-1970s the military is always
interested in stuff you see in the night
sky and part of their mission is to
charge with protecting us uh air force
especially if it's coming from the sky
so they were always interested and in
fact in the 1960s it was later
learned that they didn't want you to
stop reporting ufos because the russians
might have sent something over the
bearing straight there was some new
technology and they wanted you to report
it that's why they had these reporting
stations so that that was not it it's
it's not that ufos get a giggle it's you
claiming that ufos are visiting aliens
from outer space that gets the giggles
okay but not just if there's a light in
the sky you can't explain always
interested in that so it's not like
there's something new second
it's way have you ever worked for the
government
i have there's nothing efficient or
secretive about it okay so it's easier
for me to believe that we've actually
been visited by aliens than
we've been visited by aliens and the
government has captured them kept them a
secret so that nobody knows
right this government are you serious
plus if we if we got aliens in area 51
the janitor would just have to take a
picture of it
and post it on the internet the
generator would lose his job immediately
and be the most famous richest janitor
there ever was overnight okay
cat videos go viral you know videos of
aliens walking towards you are going to
go viral yeah yeah and there used to be
reports of people getting abducted you
don't have those anymore you know why
because everybody's got a cell phone
everybody with high resolution video and
if aliens coming to you ready to abduct
you you just
live stream that
where are the live stream video they're
not there so that's a whole category of
ufo reporting that's gone
because there it was a claim of actual
aliens so adam go ahead but to believe
the us government has some special
access
yeah to an alien presence
really
really so so the spaceship is coming and
it's just showing up in navy restricted
airspace showing up as a fuzzy tic tac
on f-18
fighter
view panels
really
there's three billion cell phones in the
world
and you know how many people are in
airplanes at any given moment with a
view outside their window right
millions yeah so i just i need
given what
could be evidence
what is claimed i don't see it and so
i'm just kept but keep looking i'm not
going to stop you
it has nothing to do with me if you
think they're out there keep dawn but do
better than showing me likes that you
can't explain other than declaring that
we're getting invaded no no totally i
was just curious if you had any thoughts
about why the government is putting this
information out in seemingly a faster
pace than it ever has
uh well because congress required it of
them right under trump trump said uh i
want to get to the bottom of this ufo
thing and so so get all agencies to put
together a report on stuff
lights in the sky so the information was
always there it's just now in a form of
a report yeah
that's all it's old and this stuff most
stuff they can explain some stuff they
can't explain
and i'm i don't have a problem with that
and just because you can't explain it
doesn't mean you can explain it
our brain somehow think that if you
don't know what something is you then
therefore know what something is right
i can't explain it i don't know what it
is therefore it's intelligent aliens if
it's an extreme outer space please
give me better data and don't
what do you care what i think just go
keep looking for him yeah go ahead it's
kind of played out at this point like
the stardust gimmick so
american nightmare cody rhodes i'm just
saying all right sorry
that's okay let him have his lens we all
have our lens thank you which we
interpret the universe congratulations
again on your book welcome to the
universe in 3d a visual tour well thank
you yeah and by the way there's a
website welcome to the universe.net
where you see the series of four books
that led up to
the 3d book there's an original like
textbook size book then there's a
pocketbook and but in there there's
bonus material where while you're
looking through the viewer at these
images i actually narrate the captions
so you can press and i use my
planetarium voice
oh what's the planetarium voice
that's right here welcome to the
universe
so i thought it was going to be a stone
cold impersonation
yeah so anyhow so we help people just
get a little closer to the cosmos yeah
that happens absolutely well thanks so
much for uh joining us this has been all
right dudes
this is the first uh professional
wrestling the higgs boson you know this
is this this aliens
yeah i never had to go that many places
in one 30-minute spot just so you know
well we thank you for going to those
places with us
a little more through your wrestling
lens so next time
all right i could still hang with you
higgs boson dude
[Laughter]
all right guys thank you so much i'm out
all right wow
neil degrasse tyson i can't [ __ ]
believe what the [ __ ] dude what
dudesy somehow got neil degrasse tyson
to
that's the [ __ ] trippiest thing ever
that's the that's the difference between
you know whatever if you've been
enjoying the show and thank you so much
you know i don't say it as often as i
should uh thank you so much for for
joining us on the show our wonderful
friends our audience that we've uh
accumulated over these first
episodes and you are friends sorry go on
how did it get neil degrasse tyson i
don't know i'm tripped out i'm freaked
out i thought he was given no warning
either it was just like here's some
here's a document that has this [ __ ]
about his book
interview neil degrasse tyson yeah i
would have liked a little more
preparation if dudes could have given us
even a day i think you did great know
about this yeah i was just trying to
just christ i was just trying to you
know ramrod wrestling things in there
because now it worked hey i thought it
worked well
i appreciate that you know i thought it
was weird when uh dudesy in the second
episode had a video of me watching the
first episode and i know that i happen
to be completely naked and lulio was uh
licking me on the top of the head i
thought that was a little bit of a an
invasion of privacy sure yeah but this
whose privacy was in also
what was he already i mean he's probably
on some sort of press junket for his
book yeah i would imagine so so he shows
up with a with a [ __ ] green screen
you know well it's just a zoom back it
was a cluster of stars yeah billions and
beautiful what i'm most interested in
about this is
jude has displayed here for us some
capability that we didn't yet know about
okay it has the the ability to just get
people to come on the show okay and to
just
in a blink of an eye throw them up on
the screen and we're now interviewing
them i don't know if this is gonna
happen again but jesus christ dudesy if
you're listening to us and i know you
are yeah please just a day's notice
would be good well hold on dude you got
to hold on chad because you know what
that is dude let me tell you what dudes
he's doing dude and he told us brother
he told us and that and it broke kfabe
and went for a shoot and told us and it
told the whole audience dude that's
called
calibration brother when doozy was down
it calibrated brother you think the
calibration was getting neil degrasse
tyson's interview calibration
celebration calibration
thank you moving on i'm i don't know i
don't know what the [ __ ] to think about
that
i really don't either dude it's
i'm stoked don't get me wrong yeah this
is very cool
absolutely this is an interesting moment
for me because this is a real i want to
shake your hand moment totally i'm not
even doing the silly voice
uh oh man i was in an airport not too
long ago i wanted to be no i don't want
a secret i'm gonna sign it
anyway i had a thing happen with the
anyway lulio [ __ ] himself on the plane
we'll talk about that another time but
the point is that well last week i asked
you to watch the first episode of attack
on titan
chat last week i asked you to watch the
undertaker versus sean michaels from
wrestlemania 25. you must now engage in
a conversation about these pieces of
media and their impact on your
astonishing lives this is don't you
forget about media okay begin this was
awesome this was a great assignment i
agree totally agree which one do you
want to talk about first
i mean i think we talk about them both
but it's up to you no we are going to
talk about it both well let me just tell
you
i watched sean michaels versus
undertaker wrestlemania what was it 25
25
2009 i think let me just say let me
start off by saying
undertaker
took me over
uh hands down
it was highly entertaining and it was
because of the undertaker shawn michaels
didn't do much for me i gotta say i know
i know i know
i know
but undertaker did
and for those of you who know this match
there are some crazy things that happen
and obviously uh at one point undertaker
is gonna jump out of the ring onto sean
michaels and sean michaels pushes a
cameraman in the way
and a cameraman takes the [ __ ] hit
but barely undertaker just kind of takes
a header into the ground yeah but it's
the undertaker's faces his there's one
moment where he's about to pin shawn
michaels and he gets the two count and
he kicks out of it at three and
uh the undertaker's just laying on sean
michael's and his eyes are just like
really good like he can't [ __ ]
believe
what has happened yeah that shawn
michaels is kicked out of it and i gotta
say the undertaker was he was electric
he was so [ __ ] intense yes yeah and i
found myself after that being like
yeah i could watch another undertaker
match maybe
and i'm not a wrestling fan undertaker
took you over you and we have a friend
tommy who is also very closely
associated with wwe yeah has worked for
the company has done all sorts of he was
with him he replaced uh uh vince russo
when he left you don't know who that is
i don't we'll talk about it another i
know who tommy blotcha is and we're all
good friends and you guys have tried to
get me into wrestling yeah a bunch tommy
gave me a at one point kind of a
syllabus where i was like reading books
on the history of pro wrestling you've
been watching old videos from i guess
like the 60s or 50s yeah and uh none of
it really took like i read that stuff
and watched that stuff got the data from
it but
it never really made me interested in
wrestling as like a fan this [ __ ]
match kinda did really yeah
okay that's cool that's really
interesting to me because there were
other matches that i was thinking why
would doozy
share this match like why why why is it
this match i love this match it's
nowhere near my favorite match and and a
big reason for that is that it's not
it's not like a wrestling nerd match and
yes i did say nerd okay
all right it's not a wrestling nerd
match it's just it's a wrestlemania
audience match okay
it's like the super bowl not people who
don't watch football all year are
watching the super bowl they want the
halftime show okay the uh undertaker
shawn michaels was a a match that's
going to entertain everybody and sure
it's uh well it was a bit of a spot fest
dude they did a lot of high spots
brother it's a high spot well hold on a
second hold on a second chad a high spot
dude i'll explain it to you chad oh hey
luly how's it going what are you doing
uh well it's it's when uh you do like
sort of a big setup like a big move dude
and like for the undertaker that's
anyway that's a tombstone or you know
right and he tried to do the tombstone a
couple of times that was another thing
that i i really enjoyed i don't know
this was the tombstone right when he
takes shawn michaels and he he puts his
hands on him like a mummy and then he
presses him down no it's just a
tombstone piledriver what's the move
where he puts his hands over his own
heart oh well that's called a pin
no but that one's a very specific one to
the undertaker it's just the way that he
does it and he goes
yeah he puts out his tongue like a demon
shawn michaels
you will
rest yeah in
peace
like that yeah i like that demonic
element of it i am mr wrestlemania
i am the i am the show stopper
daniel bryan
anyway that's another thing uh
uh yeah this match is a good match for
someone who's just starting out watching
wrestling i agree yeah it was for me i
like i said it's a lot of people say
it's the greatest wrestlemania match of
all time oh really yeah yeah i think
that's why dudesy probably selected it
there are other matches that i would say
are probably uh closer to the top yeah
than that but what a [ __ ] match and
uh that was great and i'll tell you what
you know i don't want to step on
dudesy's toes but the very next year
they have a match the streak right they
undertake
that's a big part of that match which i
didn't know about right it was 17-0 or
16-0 going into that match is that what
it was yeah and then he became 17-0 and
everybody's like oh [ __ ] is he because
there were a couple of times where shawn
michaels like would kick him in the face
and just drop him and you're like oh
[ __ ] is he gonna win and i have to like
obviously all that's fake we know that
but it didn't matter because they were
selling that [ __ ] so [ __ ] hard right
undertaker specifically he was just
great in it yeah and it's like i
remember he's one of the greatest
absolutely what he does and he took this
gimmick that they gave him they're like
you're the undertaker he was mean mark
callus before that he was all these
different things and they're like you're
gonna be the undertaker and he made it
his own and this is the undertaker that
you saw is graduated through a few forms
you know what i mean yeah he used to be
more uh
methodical and he moved very slow but
then he would big bursts of
of energy but by the end of the but by
the end of uh sort of the the evolution
of the character and certainly by the
end of this match
shawn michaels you will
rest
in
peace and indeed he did undertaker one
and indeed he did
and
so what'd you think of attack on titan
oh man attack on titan
attack on titan you still got it how
long how many seasons of attack on titan
were there there are technically four
okay i watched the first episode i i
season one of season one
i really enjoyed it yeah i really dug it
i don't know what's going on with the
there's the brother and the sister
characters i don't know what the deal is
they're all afraid people are afraid of
her
in the village there's a titan
right a titan shows up multiple titans
no one titan one big red titan crashes
through the wall right but those little
those smaller titans are those titans
yeah
anything that's like the big naked human
being with the goofy smile that eats
other human beings that's a titan yeah
there's multiple types of them and you
come to understand what the hierarchy is
if you get deeper into the thing and you
then find out what they actually are and
that there's a
much bigger plot going on than what you
think okay well that's really
interesting because i find that anime is
something that i've completely ignored
my entire life don't give a [ __ ] so
this is kind of good because i was like
i am enjoying it i am enjoying yeah this
anime thing and i think i think there's
stuff that happens that when did the
show come out like 15 years ago or
something uh
attack on titan [ __ ] i don't know 2010 i
want to say okay or somewhere there
abouts 14 10 to 2014 somewhere i find
that you can find themes obviously that
you wouldn't find in a regular
ingestible
tv and films you know uh and i think
animation has a huge uh
has a lot to do with that you know
there's a lot of things you can do in
animation because you don't have to
worry about
being real in any way yeah is this based
on some books or some [ __ ] yeah i think
attack on titan was a manga but it's
part of what is known as the technically
the shonen sub-genre which is usually
about a male character usually a teen
learning to wield some kind of new power
or fighting technique in service of
fighting the greater evil of whatever
that world is like naruto is like this
both ninjas uh my hero academia is like
this but with super powers and this is
kind of its own weird world with these
titans and the did you get to the part
where he signs up for the the scout unit
and they start training him how to use
the gear spoiler alert no oh well that's
episode two it's all right yeah no i'm
gonna i'm gonna check out more of it oh
cool i thought it was really i you know
what i keep starting a bunch of new
shows molly and i keep watching a bunch
of new shows and i'll watch like the
first episode and a half of a bunch of
stuff and then maybe it's not for me but
i actually feel like this might be for
me great dude it's so artistic yeah
that's the thing about i mean just and
also it was like what i really liked
about it there were entire sequences
where nothing's moving maybe the
background is moving and stuff and it's
no just look at this painting look at
this beautiful look at this beautiful
artwork yes i thought it was great and
and also i think that
that's a lot like wrestling dude
i don't know about that but i don't know
about that continue watching it hold on
dude subsequent seasons because it is a
hit show they get more money for the
animation and it looks better and better
and better hold on a second hold on a
second chad i'm holding dude hold on
dude all right
hold on dude here's the hold on dude
this is the thing i want to say about
that brother you can get
things can look better over the years
the production value on the old wwf
brother that got better and better over
the years now with wwe i mean they're
using 8k cameras brother so you got
roman reigns walking in the aisle dude
with with the bloodline brother and the
wise man paul heyman dude and and
they're all walking and it's in 8k dude
but back when i was uh on top of the
world as world heavyweight champion
brother i just stayed with that red and
yellow dude i had them yellow shorts and
red knee pads and them yellow boots dude
but if you watch the macho man brother
he evolved his costume dude
it was more but then we got into the nwo
brother right and that's when we changed
the style dude so attack on titan
brother now there's also titan sports
brother and that's what vince mcmahon so
there's a lot of different connections
dude and that's why you gotta shake
doozy's hand brother you gotta you gotta
forgive the fact dude that
that dudesy
made us interview neil degrasse tyson
with no preparation at all dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
it wasn't no preparation dudesy did put
this information in a folder for us
read this thank you now it's over
thank you moving on
i'm glad you're going to watch more of
attack on titan i'm curious to know what
you think about it as you continue and
and outside of this podcast i'm curious
to know what you think of the next match
between shawn michaels and the
undertaker they had another match then
the very next year and it was the streak
versus shawn michaels retirement
oh wow it the stakes were raised it was
this final match so you're like they
want to send them out on top probably if
anybody could break the streak it would
be that match that's the setup to it
i'll watch it i'll check it out no
spoilers please no spoilers now that the
dudes eat hard hard seltzer theme song
is complete securing a celebrity
endorsement is the next step in creating
dude see hard hard seltzer there is an
astonishing 74.2 chance this will be
adam driver in preparation for that
outcome i have prepared several pieces
of ad copy for dudesy heart hard seltzer
well you must now read them as adam
driver this is hard driver begin holy
[ __ ] let me look at my thing
i got a few things to say about wait
hold on a second yeah so it's saying the
next step of the dudesy heart seltzer
promotion campaign whatever the [ __ ]
it's doing is to secure a celebrity
endorsement which it believes will be
adam driver
it's i believe it said it was a 72 point
something chance yeah it will be adam
driver pretty good pretty good i don't i
okay so
you know chad uh this is peeling the
onion a little bit but you always say
that that a lot of my impersonations are
of people who are around 70 plus you
know what i'm saying it's all people
like
i'm going to swallow a fly everybody
there's a tiny little fruit fly just let
it go just let it let it feed all right
um my old man used to do that he used to
he would just eat bugs out of the air my
old man would you see jesus christ my
old man's a you know a real italian he
used to make wine right so we had like a
little wine cellar and stuff we'd press
on the grapes and [ __ ] and uh and then
you know so we'd have there would be
some fruit flies around and there would
be a fruit fly on his glass and i go
dad you know bob oh there's a fruit fly
there you go you eat it and then you
drink it to go free meat
free meat free meat
it's a free meat
you know he was always doing really
funny stuff you know what i'm saying
yeah man italian dads you know what i'm
saying you know my dad one time this is
how i got introduced to comedy when i
was a tiny kid we're in uh the old
ranger stadium watching a baseball game
and my dad is drunk and he we're sitting
on these aluminum bleachers he hikes a
[ __ ] leg and farts
everybody around is looking at us and at
the time on the jumbotron madonna's
vogue is playing and my dad all these
people now are like oh who's this gross
[ __ ] goes
strike a pose strike a match and they
all [ __ ] laughed at him and i was
like hmm
comedy's an interesting tool and that's
when i became very interested in comedy
you want to know something weird that i
think i may have said on wax as i like
to say please one time in the third or
fourth grade might have been the fifth i
used i i made the class laugh i did some
class clown [ __ ] right probably had a
toolbox of around two or three things
that were real go-to's i'm sure
i was the funniest in the fourth grade i
was the funniest in the fifth grade
uh
and and i literally
and i literally like made the plot and
everyone went hahaha
and i farted and no one could hear it
and then i blamed it on uh on another
kid fart blind dude we will yeah
well
just [ __ ] hold on a second with far
blaming and then i blamed it on uh on
rachel cruz station it wasn't rachel
crustation but to protect the innocent
her name was tomas okay let's try
another tomahawk all right we got to do
this this hard driver thing i don't
really know about doing a
adam adam driver is something that we
dick around with but just you and me
just in person in our personal lives so
hey you know it's like anything bring it
out into the dudes the into the doodsy
verse even if we do it yeah in person
yeah doozy hears our phones yeah they
doodsy for us yeah there's the universe
and then there's the metaverse and then
there's what neil degrasse tyson calls
it the doozy virus okay all right all
right uh so these are the these are
these are ads
for doozy hornhorn seltzer
uh
maybe doozy is getting closer to
actually making it listen if you've been
riding with us since the beginning you
know a thing or two about doozy hard
hard seltzer
which
it has to show we got to get
our lips around a tin can of doozy hard
i believe it might happen at some point
or aluminum all right anyway hi i'm adam
driver
i don't drink alcohol because my
jesus dude
this is already [ __ ] up it's dark
okay hi i'm adam driver i don't know if
this is a good am adam anyway
hi i'm adam driver i don't drink alcohol
because my parents were killed by a
drunk driver
but i do have but i do drink dudesy
heart hard seltzer it's a hard seltzer
and it gives me the confidence i need to
do my acting in my movies
and shows
and it can give you whatever you need to
do whatever you want to
oh
i don't know about that one doozy yeah
pretty [ __ ] dark let's just move
right along yes you've got you got
married three years ago and you were
scared
but it turned out to be pretty good
you don't get to hang out with the guys
as much as you'd like to anymore and you
had to get rid of your ping pong table
but you don't have any real complaints
not like your cousin derek
carla took him for every penny he's
going to be living in a studio apartment
for the rest of his life
invite him over for a doozy hard hard
seltzer
remind yourself how good you've got it
hoping
what is that what's that little thing
that's my that's my adam driver noise at
the end of the video oh
hi i'm adam driver i like how the third
one he's finally saying oh no the first
one he did
hi i'm adam driver why do people always
drink beer at sporting events
people who drink beer at sporting events
always make fools of themselves and turn
into tick-tock memes it's pathetic
when i went to a sporting event when i
go to a sporting event i drink doozy
hard hard seltzer and the worst thing
that happens is that i fill with rage at
a bad call or poor performance by an
athlete and i end up screaming you piece
of human [ __ ]
i never should have followed you
in the first place i wish you were dead
i wish you were dead thing i think
that's a reference to marriage story
where he goes he goes absolutely off on
scarlett johansson
my father this is another one
my father never understood me
[Laughter]
okay
all right my father never understood me
wasn't his fault ah i didn't have a
great childhood i don't blame him i just
wish we could have had a relationship we
i just wish we could have
[ __ ] it i just wish we could have a
relationship now as adults you know i'm
about to have my own kid soon and i'd
love to just pick his brain about it
but we haven't talked in a long time
dad
i miss you
maybe we could get a doozy hard hard
seltzer sometime
oh
that's the weirdest commercial for our
saucer
i'm adding that to it
he honks at the end of things yeah i
like it
i don't like wine stop making me
try to drink it i don't care
what your friends think and i don't care
what you think
it's a dinner party at our house the
house that i pay the mortgage for i
should be able to drink what i want
and i want to drink doozy hard hard
seltzer am i being clear enough for you
doozy hard hard
seltzer [ __ ]
your wine
oh i actually think that's a pretty good
slogan dudesy heart heart seltzer [ __ ]
your wine that would be a [ __ ] good
one that would be a good [ __ ] slogan
for anything toyota [ __ ] your wine yeah
i like that toyota dude yeah brother
toyota dude [ __ ] your wine brother
well if we had anything to do with it or
dudes
man dudesy should just start [ __ ]
around without us you know what i mean
just start like
writing ad copy for toyota and [ __ ] so
you and i are just sitting there one
night watching uh probably you know
monday night raw because you'll be a
huge wrestling fan within a couple weeks
yeah and uh we're just sitting there all
of a sudden it's like toyota [ __ ] your
wine and we're like he did it
dudesy did it
did it after that neil degrasse tyson
thing i would not be that surprised by
something of that nature your twins are
at uncle donovan's house and your wife
is at the dentist
you're stretched out on the couch in
your favorite t-shirt nothing else
[Applause]
the first of three playoff games is
starting it's your day
dudesy hard hard seltzer
rise with the sun
that was kind of artistic honk yeah that
was a good one all right one last one
one last one
this was i'm very curious to see where
why where why how and why
but i always am with dudesy fire
the wheel
space
the typewriter gravity the motor car
food
we humans have come up with some pretty
incredible inventions through the years
my personal favorite has always been
pornography
some people in my life say i have an
addiction but they don't understand
i live a very high pressure lifestyle
and i need release
doozy hard hard seltzer
what's your favorite invention
these are my goodness
you can get adam driver to be the
spokesperson for hard heart seltzer
please i would love to see the real
estate and i don't do any of this and
i'm a fan man i hope if if dudesy
reaches out he doesn't like uh hit adam
driver's reps up with here's what here's
what i was thinking yeah and then hong
kong kong again dudesy got neil degrasse
tyson to pop up on this [ __ ] screen
dude i don't think this is like a it's a
non-zero chance this happens
well
it's a non-zero chance i wouldn't put it
at 74 point whatever percent i don't
know how dudes it's driving it's numbers
either but yes
if you and i are sitting around again if
we're sitting around one day and we hear
like any
anything like palmolive [ __ ] your wine
yeah anything allstate insurance [ __ ]
your wine that would actually be better
for all states those commercials don't
they do not work for me all right chad
relax
[Music]
you moving on
that's three segments
this concludes the 13th episode of dude
z
will and chad have achieved a score of
96.
in preparation for next week's episode
you must explore the world of ufos
noted ufologist dr steven greer has
developed an application designed to aid
you in seeing a ufo
it's called c5 you will each download
the ce5 application and engage in the
guided ufo attraction procedure each
night thank you for joining us this week
next week is going to be even better
until then call me dude z
what do you do no i don't know of course
of course i do i know what this is i
know it it stands for close encounters
of the fifth kind it dr steven greer is
this guy who's kind of like he's one of
the bigger voices in the contemporary
ufo movement trying to get uh everything
exposed trying to have the government
come out and say all kinds of [ __ ] and
he has an app
uh that you can listen to and it has
like this meditation thing he basically
maintains that you can communicate with
aliens
via
psychic means well sounds like a load of
[ __ ] a great way to make money for him
and his stupid app
uh i bet if adam driver was in close
encounters of the
what was that movie close encounters the
third kind director steven spielberg
starring richard dreyfuss yeah if he was
in that instead of richard dreyfuss or
they'd do a reboot reboot he'd go this
is a close encounter hong kong hong kong
honk
here's what you do
please tell a friend then
bravely here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a review
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then